grogu or as he's affectionately known
baby Yoda has been through a lot even
though he's only 50 years old the former
Padawan and now surrogate's son to
everyone's favorite Mandalorian has had
quite the adventures across the galaxy
far far away
the entire Star Wars universe takes
place in a galaxy far far away so it has
its own way of measuring history since
it's one of the most important events in
the Galaxy's history Star Wars uses BBY
before the Battle of Yavin and ABY after
the battle of Yavin to Mark time the
Battle of Yavin takes place in Star Wars
Episode 4 A New Hope it's when Luke
Skywalker joins a group of courageous
Rebel Alliance fighters to attack the
Death Star while this is a smaller
battle by Star Wars standards his whole
significant weight Luke blasts the
planet destroying would be Omega weapon
into space dust and the loss of the
Death Star stands as a major setback for
the Empire the Mandalorian begins in 9
ABY that's 25 years before the force
awakens and five years after the events
of Return of the Jedi now that the
Empire has been defeated the Rebel
Alliance is trying to rebuild the Galaxy
peacefully meanwhile the mandalorians
are still spread out and without a home
dengaren is saved by a group of
religious mandalorians who train him in
their ways as a bounty hunter however
his entire life changes when he accepts
a mission to collect a mysterious
package for the now fallen members of
the Empire he discovers the package as
baby grogu and decides to save him
rather than let the Empire experiment on
him grogu was likely born in the same
year as Anakin Skywalker 41 BBY making
him 50 years old by the time the
Mandalorian begins this tracks as Jin is
initially told that he must retrieve a
50 year old asset and deliver him to his
clients however when he finds grogu he
sees that he looks and acts like a baby
there's a reason for this grogu is the
same species as Yoda in the show Mando
is told that this species ages
differently and could live for centuries
but that's about all we know about them
Star Wars Creator George Lucas admitted
to movie phone that when he created Yoda
a Jedi master was designed to fill the
void left by Obi-Wan Kenobi's death in A
New Hope looking for a Jedi master
oh get that Master Yoda you seek Yoda
Lucas knew that he needed someone to
train Luke so he made Yoda without much
thought to any background for his
species however he quite liked how the
ambiguity gives Yoda an aura of mystery
in keeping that mystery alive the
Mandalorian show winners Dave filoni and
John Favreau decided to honor Lucas's
original idea of Yoda's past being a
mystery season two of The Mandalorian
gives audiences more information
regarding grogu's enigmatic past as it's
established that he's 50 years old and a
Jedi it stands to reason that grogu
would be around during the Clone Wars as
a Padawan luckily the show does not
disappoint when detailing grogu's
timeline rogu shares with Ahsoka Tano
that he was raised in the Jedi Temple on
Coruscant and in 19 BBY he witnessed and
survived order 66. Ahsoka deduces that
someone protected him and took him out
to the temple but everything after that
is murky as grogu has seemingly blocked
those memories Order 66 is a dark moment
in Star Wars history it's when the
Empire and ax inhibited chips that have
been installed in every Clone Trooper's
brain they were put in the Clones to
prevent them from being too aggressive
given that their genetic Source material
came from Jango Fett however the Empire
uses the chips to dictate the clone's
behavior patterns and in the words of
Clone Trooper fives the chips are built
into our genetic code to make us do
whatever someone wants
even kill the Jedi across various Star
Wars properties audiences have witnessed
the brutality of Order 66 from Revenge
of the Sith the Clone Wars and even in
video games like Star Wars Jedi Fallen
order and we can add the Mandalorian to
that list as poor grogu saw its all go
down with the Empire hunting down the
remaining Jedi after Order 66 grogu has
an excellent reason to keep his head
down during those years perhaps as a
result not much is known about his time
before meeting Mando one thing is clear
though once the rebels take down the
Empire the remainder of the evil
government begins looking for grogu so
they can experiment with his
midichlorians at some points they
successfully capture him before he's
taken by nixo mercenaries this is when
the Imperials commission Mando to
retrieve grogu and return him to their
Sciences for further testing luckily
jarin chooses to save grogu instead and
the two have been on the run ever since
how the NATO mercenaries managed to
capture grogu from the Imperials is
unclear but once word spreads that they
have him it becomes an all-out battle
for Mundo to safely retrieve the child
however there is an internet Theory out
there that suggests that nixo
mercenaries are actually the good guys
after all they rescued grogu from the
Imperials and fight to protect him
against the bounty hunters looking to
collect perhaps The Mercenaries could be
prisoners or former slaves of the Empire
laying down their lives to protect an
innocent child from being delivered the
same fate the experience at the hands of
the Imperials season 2 of the
Mandalorian really ties together the
Star Wars Universe not only does it pull
on events from the films but it also
brings in characters from The Clone Wars
with live-action actors in episode 3 the
heiress Mando meets bokotan kries from
the Clone Wars she teaches Mando more
about Mandalorian culture and eventually
shares her knowledge of the Jedi as she
fought with them once upon a time she
points him in the direction of Ahsoka
Tano which results in her long overdue
live-action debut once Mando brings
grogu to Ahsoka she ultimately decides
not to train a little one to become a
Jedi shocked Mando questions why as his
entire goal at this point is fighting
Kroger with his people the Jedi she
tells him that grogu has grown too
attached to Mundo and that's a Jedi with
a strong attachment is dangerous she saw
firsthand how Anakin's and healthy
relationship and attachment to Padme
brings about his downfall and she vows
not to let grogu down that road
interestingly Ahsoka sees his attachment
in grogu immediately as she knows that
his Destiny is not to become a Jedi
however it takes Luke time to come to
this realization as he takes grogu to
train him at the end of season 2.
ultimately Luke discovers that grogu's
heart is internet and lets him decide
which path he wants to follow training
to be a Jedi or be with his father din
jarin once Ahsoka refuses to train grogu
she leaves Mando with some hope telling
him to take the child to meditate at the
seeing Stone on the planet typhoon she
shares that the stone has a strong
connection to the force and that grogu
can use it to reach out to any other
Jedi close by Mando and grogu travel to
tython where he's ambushed by Imperials
looking to capture grogu luckily Mando
manages to partner with Boba Fett and
and fellow Bounty Hunter fenik Shand to
fight against the soldiers unfortunately
grogu is successfully captured resulting
in mundo planning a daring rescue of his
little friend
he will be back with me
he means more to me
than you will ever know and while the
two are eventually reunited the team is
trapped by moth Gideon's dark Troopers
luckily grogu managed to connect with a
Jedi after all as Luke comes to rescue
the team he tells grogu that he will
take him away to train which results in
an emotional farewell between grogu and
Mundo as Mundo is part of an extremely
religious set of mandalorians he isn't
supposed to remove his helmet and the
presence of others however he chooses to
remove it so that he can look grogu in
the eye to say goodbye this act of love
between pseudo Father and Son holds
significant weight for Mundo as once his
helmet has been removed his role as a
Mandalorian within his sectors now void
however he doesn't care in this case a
proper goodbye is more important
once grogu makes his decision to leave
Luke and his Jedi training behind he is
reunited with Mundo together the two
form their own little Clan at this point
it looks like Mando is gearing up to
restore the mandalorians and get them
back to their home world of Mandalore in
the Mandalorian season three our people
are scattered like stars in the galaxy
both Mando and grogu make conscious
decisions to pick each other over
everything else regardless of the
ramifications they see each other as
family which gives a Mandalorian a
thematic link to the broader Star Wars
Universe right from the beginning the
bonds of family especially fathers from
relationships are one of the franchise's
most prominent themes as far as the
films go the broken connections of the
Skywalker family unit are the primary
force pushing the story forward the
Mandalorian is telling a new tale about
the bonds of a father-son relationship
between Mando and grogo much like Luke
is willing to sacrifice himself for his
father in Return of the Jedi grogu and
Mando are willing to sacrifice
everything they know for each other
grogu takes a pass on becoming a Jedi Ai
and Mando removes his helmet and
forfeits his position as a Mandalorian
season 2 of the Mandalorian and the
triumphant return of Luke Skywalker and
while a much older version of Luke
appears in 2015's a force awakens and
its sequels seeing Luke during his Prime
in the days following the events of
Return of the Jedi was a treat for some
fans however at the time it was pretty
disappointing how Luke didn't meet
Ahsoka she was Anakin's apprentice and
likely never knew that he turned back
for the light side right before he met
his end luckily the book of Boba Fett
fixes all of this just when everyone is
settling into Boba Fett's series on the
Sandy Hills of Tatooine Mando arrives at
Tire Blue sends in preparation for his
next season her audiences amando's
Centric episode in the middle of Boba
Fett show felt a little unusual but who
are we to argue that being said audience
says finally got to watch a conversation
between Luke and Ahsoka but she
reminisces on how much he reminds her of
his father to which he responds with a
knowing look she offers him words of
wisdom as Luke wonders what he should do
next she cautions Luke about the strong
bond between grogu and Mando before
leaving as fans are left to wonder if
the two will ever shed a screen again in
her upcoming series as the Mandalorian
continues we predict more of grogu's
story will be uncovered however one
thing will likely stay the same the
mystery surrounding his species as
mentioned previously grogu is a member
of the same species as Jedi Master Yoda
Yoda is an incredibly powerful extremely
wise Jedi in Star Wars lore however most
people don't realize that aside from
Yoda and grogu there's another member of
their species featured in the timeline
initially shown in The Phantom Menace
yaddle is a Jedi council member and his
present during the evaluation of young
Anakin Skywalker however by attack of
the Clones she has disappeared luckily
yalos's appearance is expanded upon in
Star Wars tales of the Jedi in the
Disney plus series she steps down from
her position on the Jedi hide Council
following the events of the Battle of
Naboo in the year 32 BBY after learning
that Count Dooku won't attend the
funeral of his old Parowan Qui-Gon Jinn
she grows suspicious of his action
follows Dooku and learns that he's
turned to the dark side of the force
when she confronts him she offers Dooku
compassion which makes it all the sadder
when Dooku kills her thus solidifying
his place next to his master Darth
Sidious also known as Emperor Palpatine